انا فلسطينيه من فلسطين من النكت قضاء عكا
احنا عيلتنا بيقولوا لبيت ابريق انا اسمي
صليحه ابراهيم ابريق
طيب طلعت من ثمان سنين
من سكان لبنان مخيم برج البراجنه
ببيروت
بشتغل انا هلا مسؤول اداره وحده الاسعاف
والطوارئ للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
بيروت انا من عكا اصولي يعني من عكا انا
كنت بتمنى لو خلقت ببلدي وكنت معالجه
نفسيه بشتغل ضمن مجاله ضمن بلدي سنه 1981
ببيروت كان عندي حب لموضوع الهندسه
الكمبيوتر يعني انا كان عمري اربع سنين
لما اخذ قرار
مشدود جدود جدود 70 جد انها بفلسطين احنا
من اول فلسطين هاي لنا مش لحدا غيرنا
طلعونا بالقوه سحبنا حالنا وطلعنا ما
لقينا غير وجهنا لبنان انا في المخيم بس
عندي قريبين كثير من المخيم الوالد طلع من
من مخيم الباص رجع حتى بقول لك يعني انا
كنت جزء كتير كبير هون الجمعيه كان تطوع
نتيجه حبي لفلسطين وبدي اشتغل على الارض
مع الشعب الفلسطيني انه انا اذا بدي اظهر
اشتغل
برا الجمعيات اللي هي الان جي اوز انا ما
فيني اشتغل بمجال لاني معجنه نفسيه اول
شيء انا لما قبل ما بيطلع لي لاني
فلسطينيه ما بيطلع للبطاقه بس تقول لي انه
العالم هون مبسوطه اكيد مش مبسوطه لانه يا
ريت نحنا ببلدنا احسن لنا واشرفنا احنا
وصغار طب ليه احنا بقولوا لنا لاجئ ما كنا
نعرف انه شو يعني كلمه لاجئ مثلا اللي
عرفنا بعدين انه جدي هو وقت النكبه 1948
تشرد تهجر قصرا صار معك كذا مره انه
يتفاجئوا انه انا فلسطيني بقول لك اللهجه
اللهجتك بتصير كانك مش فلسطين بس انا بعتز
انه انا فلسطيني وبحب حافظ على هويته انا
اصلا متزوج مدامتي لبنانيه وخلقت والبيت
حتى بالمجتمع اللبناني يعني انا موجود
بمنطقه معظم سكانها لبنانيه
[ضحك]
فقراء هاي النظره لنا اكنه شو احنا يعني
مش بشر على العالم يعني انت ما بتعرف بكره
شو حيصير لانه انت مش بوطنك انت مش ببلدك
من حقي اكون مواطن يعني ببلدي اللي انا
بنتمي لالها اكيد برجع بتعرف ليه لانه في
شيء اسمه كرامه وفي شيء اسمه وطن اذا انا
ماني ببلدي مني عايشه بين اهلي وبين ناسي
ما حكون مرتاحه واذا قدر الله وبيوم من
الايام تحررت فلسطين او صحلنا انه نرجع
انا بدي ارجع على فلسطين هلا ما بعرف اذا
بستقر هونيك او لا بترجع زي اي مواطن باي
بلد
ومنرجعونا عيب على اللي ما بتنصب شادر
بتقعد تحتيه
الامم القيام ينصبول
يغيروها ويطبروها ما قالوا انه جرين
الكبير بموت والصغير بنساه لكن ما فشر لكل
من بده يطابع على هاي الاشي ما بنقبل ابدا